littoral avec moi jean tremblay maire de
saguenay depuis 20 ans qui tire vous le
savez sa référence monsieur le maire
bonsoir bonsoir
est-ce que vous avez des regrets non
vous n'êtes pas du tout mais je regarde
ça avec intérêt ça fait peut-être un peu
drôle parce que habituellement
j'étais sur le terrain là j'étais
présent partout mais non je suis très
content de m'être retirer j'ai je lui
dis ça fait un an que je le dis si je me
présente je voudrais même pas pour moi
je trouve que c'est assez
vous étiez tannique 6 et là j'étais
tanné de me voir oui lyon ils y ont même
fait un sondage gis a pas longtemps
pimont inclus dans le sondage je
comprends pas alors que vous fassiez
j'ai jamais vues sont moins claires un
sondage sérieux bien inclure une
personne qui confirme qu'il n'y ait
qu'il n'ira auquel ni rapport alors
qu'ils mènent dans ce sondage la même
chose et gabla d'entasser sur deux tu
vas gagner ça m'intéresse pas qu'est ce
que monsieur tremblay qu'est ce qui a le
plus changé dans le monde municipal
par rapport à vos débuts à 20 ans puis
votre carrière
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
sentez dans le monde municipal au québec
la quéquette plus du tout pareil
mais d'abord tout s'est tu c'est moins
pire là vous abonner en avait parlé mais
toute cette ambiance de corruption qui a
eu lieu là surtout lors de la dernière
campagne
c'est vraiment désagréable j'avais moi
je ya 2 % des mères il ya 2 % des
policiers il ya 2 % des journalistes moi
je toujours gain de 2% lors qu'ils sont
pro avec lyon sa municipalité 2% ça fait
plusieurs mères puis on avait
effectivement sauf que ça rejaillit sur
tout le monde mais d'une façon très
intense
ça a été une période déplaisante et puis
le gouvernement aussi nous aider contre
injecteurs ministre à venir vous dire
que l'or maintenant les villes jour
beaucoup plus autonome je pose sur
d'autres sorts l'ona n'en n'auront
jamais su attaquer mais elles le sont
ils ont plus de pouvoir donc voila vous
devriez voir des contraintes qu'on a
avec le ministère de l'environnement le
ministère des affaires municipales je
vous le dis c'est devenu tellement l'eau
les appareils municipales sont tellement
lourde les fonctionnaire au ministère
des affaires la municipale nous donne
nous demandent toutes sortes de
d'eghezée
en ce qu'ils font en sorte que des
projets n'avancent port d'ailleurs le
québec peut on n'a pas parlé pendant
campagne mais le québec qui avant sport
que les municipalités c'est un outil de
développement extraordinaire
si on compte mais y avance peut-être un
peu mais si on se compare à l'ontario la
colombie britannique et à monsieur
tremblay quoi on va noter l'heure vous
êtes en train de me faire un discours
comme candidat aux prochaines élections
provinciales vous non mais c'est la
vérité
non la vérité c'est que est ce que vous
êtes courtisé par un parti oui mais je
le suis mais je pense que c'est toi
réflexion non oh non l'élève les parties
sollicite délit maires des villes
importantes sont à peu près tous
sollicités j'en suis
alors moi comme les autres j'ai été
sollicité à presque toutes les élections
c'est normal mais je vous dire que je
suis en réflexion que je me prépare pour
la prochaine élection là effectivement
le nom j'aimerais actuellement l'âge et
la taille est vite je veux me vider la
tête refus au moins jusqu'au jusqu'au
mois de janvier là je me repose ça fait
vingt et un stress intense le travail
d'un maire puis là je veux prendre du
bon temps et au mois de janvier
je regarde je dis pas non mais
honnêtement j'ai pas ça dans la tête
lors je me prépare pas ce qu'ils gagnent
chez vous ce soir monsieur tremblay pas
des héros monsieur monsieur blackburn
madame néron est en avance ça d'une
façon importante je pense qu'elle va
gagner ce soir
oui je vais pas voter pour elle mais je
pense qu'elle va gagner
j'ai voté pour qui j'ai voté pour
dominer gagnant il est arrivé en dernier
il n'y a pas eu la chance de se faire
connaître beaucoup mais d'après moi
c'est la personne qui a le plus de
potentiel ou est-ce que vous êtes
brouillé avec jean pierre blackburn
aussi mais j'avais raison d'une bonne
histoire de brouiller des fois ça fait
du bien aujourd'hui que c'est pas bon de
chicaner via des chicanes sans payet
dans certaines occasions et personnages
comme vous je vais arrêter avec ça parce
qu'il faut continuer l'émission on est
des personnages comme vous
y en a de moins en moins aux municipales
ou si c'est comme s'ils allaient le
niveau d'acceptation pour du franc
parler puis des fois j'avais dit un peu
des niaiseries on va s'entendre vous et
moi des fois ça vous est arrivé alors on
dirait que vous êtes vraiment le type de
merck on élisait pour 20 ans justement
mais que cette période là et des révolue
les derniers sondages passant qui dit à
mon sujet je savais bien des regrets ok
mais on va surveiller votre réflexion
comme candidat d'un parti à l'election
québécoise
chaque ovarien entendent par mx merci
nous avons parlé va devoir mrc